after years of waiting fans of Five
Nights at Freddy's are finally getting
the movie adaptation they've been
wanting so how can Blum House's next big
project revolutionize the horror genre
take a look inside if you dare
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria
where fantasy and fun come to life Five
Nights at Freddy's is an insanely
popular video game franchise that's
finally getting the big screen treatment
after years of languishing and
development blumhouse is finally making
a film come to fruition that will have a
simultaneous release in theaters and on
peacock on October 27 2023. there's a
ton of anticipation built up towards the
Five Nights at Freddy's movie and
whether that's in the cinema or on the
couch plenty of people are going to see
it but it still raises the question of
whether or not the film will actually be
any good and whether or not it'll
utilize horror tropes in entertaining
ways so what's the one horror Trope that
we expect Five Nights at Freddy's to fix
by the jump scare of course while often
maligned by horror film enthusiasts the
Five Nights at Freddy's games are
perfect examples of the form as a player
clicks their way through a dark
restaurant their field division will
often be hampered right before an evil
animatronic comes out of nowhere to
startle them players who have kept up
with the games have come to expect them
but General audiences may be more
reluctant to give the film a chance if
it's over reliant on Sudden shock
hopefully the film uses the technique in
innovative ways so that casual audiences
aren't as turned off by the story The
Five Nights at Freddy's movie is going
to be PG-13 and those types of horror
films tend to rely on jump scares
because they don't require blood or Gore
in the Five Nights at Freddy's games
jump scares work better than they often
do in movies because the action is seen
in first person players see exactly what
their character sees making the
animatronics lurking around the corner
all the more Sinister the movie
adaptation won't keep a first-person
perspective all of the time so jump
scares may not always work as well
doesn't mean the film should avoid them
entirely though instead they should be
interspersed with other frightening
images for an all-around haunting
experience the Five Nights at Freddy's
games have plenty of terrifying moments
and not all of them are of the jump
scare variety even though it seems like
the movie will mostly adapt elements
from the first game there are many
lessons and effective four to be learned
throughout the series from the use of
lighting to fake outs that make players
paranoid there are numerous ways to amp
up the sense of dread before hitting the
audience with a jump scare that way it
feels like it's been earned many horror
fans to ride jump scares for being cheap
and easy but adding more substance to
them could allow the Five Nights at
Freddy's movie to stay true to its roots
while scaring newcomers and Veterans
alike
we're going to have so much fun together
the first trailer for Five Nights at
Freddy's came out on May 16th and fans
are ecstatic at how faithful it looks
like it'll be to the original games the
pizzeria has a new night security guard
Mike played by Josh Hutcherson who
quickly learns that not all his fun and
games when Freddy Fazbear is involved
among the images teased are a saw-style
trap made out of an animatronic head and
Matthew Lillard as the villain William
Afton
the trailer does suggest that jump
scares will be a part of the proceedings
after all there's one moment where the
red eyes at the titular evil bear glow
ominously in the darkness there's also
an ominous moment at the end where a
child hides in a ball pit only to be
found by Freddie and his friends
it still remains to be seen if Five
Nights at Freddy's will be among the
jump scare greats and horror genre a
scientific study actually found a scene
in Insidious how the most effective jump
scare of all time the viewers heart
rates jumping to a staggering 133 beats
per minute it's a high bar to clear but
if there's any upcoming film up to the
task It's Five Nights at Freddy's
thank you
[Music]